hello everybody and welcome back to
another video um today i've been putting
off making this video for a while just
because
i don't know you ever just like have
some topic that you know you have to
eventually get to and you just really
don't feel like doing it because you
like kind of know about it but not
enough and you don't really care about
the research
well that's kind of what happened here
so anyway let's get through tcp versus
udp and we'll call it a day okay tcp and
udp
what are they well basically the network
is this super complex thing right that
you have a bunch of cables going around
the routers in between and you're
sending bits over these networks and um
they're totally unstructured to start
and somehow we've made it such that you
know the network is what it is today
where you can basically send you know
ordered information and useful
information over what's effectively just
ones and zeros which is pretty crazy but
in order to basically do this the
network has established a bunch of
protocols which means it's established
basically a bunch of standards of how
data is sent and and how it should be
sent and how it should be formatted so
that all devices on the network can you
know send this data in a standard way
and then you know actually be able to
use it so in particular the two
protocols that i'll be talking about
today are tcp and udp which both operate
at the transport layer and so basically
there are significant differences
between the two of them but at the end
of the day the job of both is to
basically just go ahead and ensure that
packets are delivered
but as you can see tcp guarantees a lot
more about the way that these packets
are going to be delivered than udp and
so as a result we're going to start by
breaking down what tcp is and how it
actually works
okay so tcp basically goes ahead and
provides reliable ordered and error
checked streams of bytes between two
computers in a network um it uses
something called sequence numbers to
deal with ordering and i'll discuss that
in a minute um it uses something called
checksums which is basically just like
every single you know
amount of bytes that's self-contained
should have the sum of those bytes and
so that way you know if something along
the network happens to cause one bit to
flip it goes ahead and alerts you that
the checksum is incorrect and as a
result you know there's some error in
the message
so that's one way of
making sure that by their bits just
aren't flipping around randomly and then
basically the way that tcp is able to
kind of make all these guarantees that i
just mentioned above are through a few
things um and we're gonna discuss all of
those so that's handshake reliable
transmission flow and congestion control
and also connection termination
so first off let's talk about the
handshake so basically instead of
something like udp where you basically
just send messages indiscriminately in
order for two nodes over the network to
go ahead and send messages to one
another they must first establish
something known as a three-way handshake
and the computer that's going to go
ahead and start out this three-way
handshake is known as the client the one
receiving it at first is known as the
server so basically it's composed of
three commands hence the three-way
handshake
where you have a syn ack and then a syn
ack so first the client sends the sim to
the server with some randomly generated
sequence number it's useful to have the
sequence number be randomly generated so
that in the future other people can't
just like guess the sequence number and
then send their own packets to the
server and then the server thinks
they're coming from the client so that's
important
the server is then going to respond with
an acknowledgement
with the acknowledgement value being the
previous sequence number plus one so x
plus one and then its own sequent number
sequence number y so what that
acknowledgement number is basically
saying is
the next time i get a message from
client to server i want the sequence
number to be x plus one and what it's
also saying is saying that
i'm starting my own sequence with y and
when we send this syn ack back with y
plus one on the synack it's saying that
the server is now only going to send
data
to the client or the next data message
from the the server to the client is
going to have the sequence number y plus
1. so the acknowledgement header
basically always says what you expect
the sequence number of the next received
message to be
so finally basically like i said the
client then receives that ack from the
server and then sends a sin and an act
so the syn has the sequence number x
plus one and then the acknowledgement
has the value y plus one so as you can
see everything should be in order here
and then like i said every
acknowledgement value just goes ahead
and says what a computer expects the
next sequence whenever it receives to be
and we can go ahead and use this to
basically
prevent messages from being duplicated
and also keeping messages in order so
how do we prevent message duplication
well we have this concept of a do back
re-transmission so basically imagine i'm
the sender and i send a packet with
sequence number 99 and that packet goes
ahead and gets lost i don't know that
it's been lost and you know i'm not
waiting for the acknowledgement just yet
but what i am going to do now
is go ahead and send the next packet
which has sequence number 100.
let's imagine this one gets through well
the receiver is going to say well
actually i never got number 99 and so
i'm going to send an acknowledgement
back
with number equals
basically 99 itself and so now i know
that i first need to send packet 99
again because 99 never actually got
there so in that sense now the sender
can basically say oh shoot you know like
i have to go ahead and re-transmit this
message because i never got the proper
acknowledgement for it
so that's kind of important to know
um additionally we now have these um
timeout based estimates where basically
if you don't receive an ack within some
timeout which is basically based on the
estimate of the round-trip time of the
network from the sender to the receiver
then you're going to basically go ahead
and resend that packet um to prevent
this from you know just happening too
often say one one of the nodes is down
and you don't want to overload the
network
we're basically using something called
an exponential back off where every
single time that we have a timeout
expiration we double our estimate of the
round trip time so that we're not just
sending tons and tons and tons of
messages but rather you know like we're
retrying at an increasing or a
decreasing frequency and this helps
protect against ddos attacks that kind
of exponential back off
okay next we have this concept of flow
control so every single node in the
network basically has a dedicated buffer
that um you know the buffer is in memory
and what this buffer does is it's saying
okay
i'm getting all of these messages over
the network and i have to put them in
this queue in memory so that i can
eventually process them because
otherwise they would just get thrown out
you have to store them somewhere before
you can actually process them
so
this can become an issue if say you know
i'm on the receiving end of a message
and i'm getting so many messages that my
buffer gets filled up and now i just
have to either start deleting or
dropping messages so tcp what it'll
actually do is it'll regulate network
flow so that the receiving device
doesn't get too much data and the way
that it actually does this is every
single one of those acknowledgments has
a separate piece of information that
basically says how many bytes are left
in that buffer
or in that flow buffer and that way the
sender will know not to go ahead and
overwhelm the receiving device
if it's the case that the receiving
device has no room left then the sender
is going to wait some period of time and
basically send a super small message in
order to get an acknowledgement
basically saying how much space is left
in the buffer so obviously you don't
want to be overloading buffers because
if you're overloading the buffer and
then you're retrying all these messages
not only now are you potentially
dropping messages but you may be
congesting the network and this is what
we're going to talk about next so we
have congestion
congestion control
so basically not only is it possible
like i said to overwhelm a receiver you
can actually overwhelm network links if
we're sending too many packets over them
and what this does is it lowers network
throughput pretty significantly and
since in tcp for you know a variety of
different reasons that i've mentioned
packets might need to be reset you know
either the receiver has too much
congestion or too many messages in the
buffer the receiver might be down or you
know one message got dropped and now it
has to be retransmitted as a result
basically
you know we're resetting all these
messages and we want to make sure that
our sending node is not congesting the
network so what do we do to actually
mitigate this typically what tcp will do
is use something known as a congestion
window where it's basically like almost
a buffer on the sender that says how
many
packets are currently being sent over a
network connection that you know haven't
yet been acknowledged and so the
congestion window starts out really
small right it might actually only be
like you know one
pack it's worth however
it basically builds up over time so as
long as acknowledgements are being set
successfully basically what we do is use
something called an additive increase
multiplicative decrease strategy where
the size of that congestive window might
grow linearly over time by receiving
acknowledgments but say that we then
realize that um you know the network is
becoming congested then what we're going
to do is take that congestion window and
half it and we're going to keep doing
that until you know we're not congesting
the network anymore so you know it's
kind of like we're very conservatively
making that window a little bit bigger
but the second we're too big we're like
oh we gotta back off and back off really
quickly
okay what about in terms of connection
termination because it's important that
you know people can open up ports again
and make sure that a client and server
can eventually both agree on the fact
that they're no longer sending messages
to one another well in order to do this
we kind of have this four-way handshake
which is not really as much as like a
four-way process but more so just two
independent two-way handshakes
and this kind of stems from the fact
that each half of the connection is
going to terminate independently and the
reason we can't terminate both of them
at the same time is kind of something to
do with this idea of a two generals
problem where two disjoint you know two
disjoint nodes or connections over an
unreliable network can't agree on
something because if i were to tell you
know if i were one server and i told the
other server
you need to you know terminate this
connection how do i know that it did
well maybe they send an acknowledgement
to me and i get that but then how does
the server know that i actually received
the acknowledgement and that problem
just keeps going going on and on and on
and on forever and so basically there's
no way to really be sure that
both sides can coordinate and close the
connection at the same time so really
you just close each half of the
connection one at a time
so basically the the initiator is going
to send a fin message and the receiver
is going to send an ack and also its own
fin message to the initiator which is
also going to send an ack then the
initiator of the the termination is
going to actually wait a certain amount
of time the reason for this being that
before actually closing the message you
want to wait a little bit of time so
that any messages that may have actually
been you know kind of like stuck in the
path between the initiator and the
receiver or vice versa can actually make
sure to be discarded because if you were
to say reopen a subsequent connection on
the same port you don't actually want to
be receiving those old messages
because that would just kind of throw
things out of whack it wouldn't make
sense why all these unrelated old
messages were still coming through so
you wait a little bit of time on the
initiator and then you close the
connection
okay what about udp well you see i have
this kind of scarface picture here of
just literally indiscriminately firing a
machine gun because that's basically
what udp is
you have your sender and your sender is
basically just going to you know grab
that all over the place and send all the
packets they want to the receiving node
and they don't care if they're you know
congesting the network they don't care
if they're sending too many messages for
the receiver's buffer they don't care if
they're drop messages or they're out of
order or anything like that they're just
sending them they're full sending it and
so udp is kind of chaotic but the truth
of the matter is it has its uses so
let's go into those
basically udp the reason for using it is
the fact that it's much faster you don't
have to establish any handshakes you
don't have to do any connection
termination you're literally just
sending messages and so there are
applications where this can be useful
you know think about video chats or you
know voice over the internet in the
sense that
you know we don't really care about
delayed video chat data getting in if we
have a buffer it's already too late just
you know hopefully we get the subsequent
video chat messages same goes for video
games same goes for stock prices if you
just want to see the most up-to-date
price
and so udp definitely has its uses but
that being said in the general case tcp
is probably going to be better for most
systems design problems where you care
about you know
the correctness of the bytes being sent
it's obviously very important that
you're not losing any data or that your
data is out of order especially when
making something like a rest request and
so as a result you know most http
requests are going to be done over tcp
and they also provide better guarantees
against ddos attacks because of that
flow and congestion control whereas udp
doesn't have any of that
okay so in conclusion um these are
pretty well established protocols at
this point and unless you're a network
engineer they're probably generally
going to be an afterthought but that
being said there are definitely some
applications where using tcp versus udp
might have extremely um big benefits to
performance or additionally possibly
even the correctness of your application
and so as a result it's kind of
important to know the difference between
these they're definitely going to be
systems design questions out there where
you're kind of asked to explain the
difference between them and in the event
that you are it's important to know them
so have a good one guys i look forward
to seeing you all in the next one